[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show well we
thought that the combination of joe
biden's state of the union address at a
time when
i don't even know what at a time when
what when people are paying attention to
a global crisis the russian invasion of
ukraine
might help him a little bit in terms of
his anemic approval ratings
and it has and i think it's important to
mention on the one hand in a new npr pbs
poll
he's up to 47 that's much higher than 39
from last month
at the same time in the 538 average of
biden approval he's up two points he's
up from 40 to 42. so i think we can say
with certainty pat
it's up his approval is up
uh but it's not necessarily up eight
points it's probably up somewhere
between two and three as the averages
point to but this was what we expected
yeah i mean it's still good to see
it's predictable in a way because
whenever there's war or conflict there's
a sort of rally around the flag effect
and in this case it's really not the
american flag that people are rallying
around it's the ukrainian flag but
you know by extension i could imagine
that biden would get a bump in approval
and also sometimes we'll see a bump
after state of the union addresses so we
had both of those factors at play here
it's not surprising at all that we see a
little bump for biden and his approval
rating was already relatively low so it
gets to a point where there's really
nowhere to go but up yeah anything
anything reasonable will bump it up yeah
but we'll have to wait and see what
happens from here because
now with uh the gas prices really
surging out of control inflation
continuing obviously americans are going
to feel this war a lot more in their own
wallets and pocketbooks and it may get
to a point where people start to blame
the president more and more and they do
away with their concerns for ukraine
because they're worried about their own
financial situation absolutely and i
think that that may happen
it may happen quickly and soon quite
frankly um the other thing about biden's
approval is
the jobs numbers have been incredible
and it doesn't really get that much
attention i mean
we've talked about f when the numbers
are expected to be not so good fox will
tease bad numbers and then there was
that incredible time where the numbers
ended up being really good and then fox
just like went completely silent on it
but the jobs numbers really are good and
i know we can always say things like
okay jobs is one factor what about wages
what about the level of quality of the
of course we always say those things
but the jobs numbers are really good and
they don't appear to be doing that much
for biden and to some degree i think
it's because they're not really getting
that much media coverage yep 678 000
jobs were added last month in february
and the unemployment rate went from four
percent to 3.8 percent that's basically
full employment right there yeah but
yeah i mean there's so many different
factors dealing with the economy that
you can always pick and choose depending
on what you want to criticize the
president on like you know just a week
or two ago
fox and these right-wing outlets they
were attacking biden for his low
approval rating now that it's bounced a
little bit they're going to go after him
for
gas prices like you can always just pick
something right and it's just sort of
normal political theater they always do
this kind of thing i am increasingly
thinking that while on the one hand
republicans over the last few years have
taken this approach of trump kept us out
of wars and biden's going to get us into
one and they're starting to apply that
to ukraine i think on the one hand
you're going to see that pressure from
republicans that biden stay out of
ukraine
at the same time
i think pressure is going to build on
joe biden to send troops to ukraine and
joe biden recently said putin will not
take ukraine period and to some degree
it's like well are you going to make
sure of that and joe biden has been
clear
we're not sending troops i believe
there's going to be a very complicated
situation very soon where there was is
going to be pressure on biden
to send troops or to do more
and some of those very people saying
biden's being weak if biden sends troops
will say look biden got us into a war
but trump kept us out of it they're
gonna try to have it both ways
yeah i mean the thing is if he's going
to send in troops you'd imagine it would
have to be done now or soon right
because this invasion could be over in
the next month or two yeah because
we don't know for sure but certainly the
odds are in russia's favor at this point
because of the amount of troops that
they have and uh you know if you get to
a point where ukraine is actually taking
over
then what's going to be the response
there is there just going to be sort of
a lull in geopolitics will everyone just
have this bad feeling about what took
place there will there be concern about
the next country that russia is looking
at uh so yeah there's a number of
different factors at play obviously but
i think by and large americans seem to
please with how biden is dealing with
the situation in ukraine now yes like
the one thing that we were maybe waiting
on was to ban russian oil imports and
now that's been done there's talk about
maybe instituting a no-fly zone which is
dangerous in its own right so there many
people are saying okay we should caution
against that by the administration's not
open to that one so like it's hard to
think about what else he could do right
now given the sentiment of the country
and what we know would be effective and
for sure for ourselves for sure no it's
a very complicated situation and i i
don't want biden sending troops to be
clear but i think there is going to come
a point at which there will be
significant pressure to do so and
significant
uh risk to doing so as well both
politically and from the standpoint of
the lives of the people that that would
go in you know over the weekend i wasn't
really paying attention to the news but
i couldn't help come across the headline
that russia has arrested a u.s olympic
champion athlete and without
investigating anymore i started to think
oh wait a second
are have they taken a hostage have they
taken a prominent hostage that they are
now going to in some way dangle related
to the invasion of ukraine
we don't know a lot but it does not at
all appear to be that that is the case
so here's what what we know and what we
don't know the u.s olympic champion is
brittany greiner brittany griner
basketball player
it is not as per cnn it's not clear
right now
where she is or exactly why she was
arrested
um she's 31 years old she plays in the
wnba with the phoenix mercury and during
the off season she plays with a russian
team
and we know that she has been arrested
it was reportedly because she was found
with hash oil at moscow's main airport
and she passed through arriving from new
york a drug dog
signaled the presence of some kind of
substance in her luggage it was
inspected
there was the presence of uh vapes
with
what is believed to be hash oil
and
that is um the cause of her being
arrested and this was reportedly
um a few several weeks ago
as of yesterday it's not clear where
griner is
and of course the fear is even if the
initial arrest was before the invasion
of ukraine
the fear is that this is now going to be
used for political purposes in some way
shape or form and that very well may be
but
not that many answers right now pat
about exactly what's going on what is
the process the legal process that she
will be subject to and even where she is
yeah it's definitely not an actual
hostage situation that seems like sort
of a de facto hostage situation because
let's say this happened in a country
where the u.s had strong diplomatic ties
uh you know somewhere else in the world
right and they similarly had these laws
against cannabis and you know you could
face five to ten prison if you're found
in possession of it yeah well i would
imagine that with someone who is a
basketball star right an olympian the
u.s
and the state department would make it
so that that person would be released
from prison and maybe never go back to
the country or something like that there
would be a diplomatic end to it but with
russia right now we don't really have
those diplomatic ties there's not a lot
of communications so you're not going to
be able to make that sort of deal and it
could mean that greiner has to actually
serve out a sentence here potentially
and uh given everything that's going on
right now obviously there's not going to
be any sort of urgency to send her back
to the u.s right
one way that they can sort of um have
some leverage over us even if it is a
very small thing
so yeah it's a very unfortunate
situation obviously but i think that's
where it stands right now the other
aspect of this that's concerning to many
people is greiner is a lesbian woman who
has a wife in the united states russia
is very unfriendly to lgbt people with
extremely strict laws there is no reason
right now to think that that is a factor
in what's going on with brittany griner
but
given the totality of the situation i
don't think that that's a mitigating
factor in what russia is going to do
with her unfortunately yeah hopefully
it's a non-factor but you just never
know because you don't really know how
uh people in russian prisons are treated
obviously people get disappeared
sometimes not guessing that's going to
happen in this case but you just you
never know you can't really trust what
what they're saying maybe there's a
possibility that uh this hash oil wasn't
actually found on her or was planted or
something like that too you have to take
that into consideration as well yeah i
mean because of the timing
i mean listen russia could have been
thinking pretty far ahead it's true but
because of the timing it doesn't seem
like that would be something but listen
anything is possible if you read bill
browder's book to the extent that you
believe what bill browder writes about
russian prisons and how people are
treated uh just about anything is
possible and uh
courts are completely corrupt in much of
the country particularly um outside of
the big cities it's we it there's no
transparency and we just don't know the
full scope of what could happen here but
obviously we are going to be following
it closely and uh like pat said because
diplomatic relations with russia have
completely broken down i don't even know
that a diplomatic solution is
probable i mean i don't want to say no
one's talking about it i'm sure there
are people talking about it but it's
just not the
the most likely scenario so we will
follow it i've talked before
about fraud related to ppp loans around
kovid
and the economic impact
monies and payment
and i've mentioned i've had
conversations with my accountant who
said you know
we believe
that the irs is really over the next
year going to go very very hard
on uh fraud related to
covet money
we have a story of a man from georgia
who was sentenced to 36 months in prison
because he used covet relief money to
buy a i hope i pronounced this correctly
uh is it charizard or is it charizard
it's charizard charizard it's a pokemon
card i know nothing about pokemon
charizard is that what you said i think
the eye is silent i just say charizard
charizard
bought a charizard pokemon card
with covid stimulus money
it's a 31 year old he got one of those
e-i-d-l loans for 85k
he said he owned a small business with
10 employees the loans were part of the
covet stimulus package available to
small business owners and of the 85k he
used almost 58 000 to buy a charizard
card
and um this card was then sold
um
the card was tracked down to a
particular auction
and uh the individual is now going to
have to do 36 years in prison plus
i'm sorry uh 36 months
what did i say 36 years
no he's not gonna he's not going to
spend 36 years in prison he's going to
spend 36 months in prison
and pay 10 000 as a fine on top of 85
000 in restitution and then have three
years of probation
this stuff has to be taken seriously i
mean this was money
it's all of our money right this is
taxpayer money which i'm fine
helping people who need it i'm not okay
with people lying about having
businesses and taking the money
yeah i mean i would understand if this
was a blastoise card for 58 000 or a
mewtwo card sure charizard i mean that
that's just pretty it's just such a weak
card to spend that much on you know yeah
and you know maybe this guy was a big
pokemon collector maybe the idea was he
could flip it because pokemon cards are
now considered assets
for whatever reason we're just seeing
this bubble and the appreciation of
pokemon cards and uh the people who who
played pokemon when they were yeah hold
on a second can we just i think
can you how are you pronouncing the word
poke ammon like as if it were uh i've
never heard that i say pokemon poke
honestly because of the little accent
over the e
i assume it's pokemon and i'm even
saying it incorrectly but i've never
heard pokemon i've also heard pokemon
yeah i know that can't be right yeah i
mean i i played a little bit but i'm not
as into it as other people are but yeah
what we've seen is like people who
played pokemon or pokemon or however you
want to say it when they were five six
seven eight years old now they're
maybe 28 to early 30s and so they can
afford to pay a lot of money for pokemon
cards and there's nostalgia to it and so
we're seeing this giant bubble and so
that sort of explains what's going on
here because i think a lot of people
would see like okay this charizard card
was worth 58 000 how could that possibly
be yeah and it just seems like it's one
of these bubbles listen former producer
lewis talks to me about the high value
of certain magic cards and i just do not
care it's uh like listen i collectibles
can be worth a lot of money i don't i
don't doubt it it just i just don't
really understand any of it um there's a
bunch of other big sentences that have
been handed down three weeks ago
uh three men were sentenced for a 2.7
million dollar covid relief fraud scheme
um two weeks ago an oakland woman was
sentenced to three years in prison in a
million dollar pandemic relief fraud
using a shell company to get money and
then spending it on private jet travel
and luxuries and vehicles and all sorts
of different things
five days ago um a man pled guilty to
schemes to defraud the programs as well
as the archdiocese of washington it
involved taking 2 million from ppp for a
spending spree bought a house yacht and
a car and it also involved the catholic
church in some way i mean these are
endless stories and the irs is going to
have its hands full for years on this
stuff yeah when these loans were given
out uh a lot of people thought like okay
this is just free money and there's
never going to be any follow-up to this
right
everyone's just getting stimulus you
don't have to worry about it now that
everything's kind of coming to an end
people are taking a look at uh what kind
of purchases were made and looking into
the fraud itself so yeah it wasn't
predicted by everyone but uh good thing
that we at the show all we spent the
loan money on was the panels and the
globe behind me exactly um and that cost
about fifty thousand dollars but aside
from that we didn't take any ppv money i
am tangentially aware of people with
shows like ours who did take money and i
don't know if they did it under the
we're gonna pay it back premise or not i
don't really know i'm not getting
involved i don't know the full scope of
it but
a lot of a lot of money was floating
around for a while
yes and of course we're just kidding we
didn't take any money no um and uh it's
probably good at this point because now
he can sleep well at night and we don't
have to worry about it no doubt about it
yeah
uh okay that is gonna do it for today we
will be back tomorrow with a new show
and a new bonus job